[Music]
for a long time if you went to the
library in Wilmington North Carolina
there was one thing you weren't allowed
to research we were refused we were
rejected by the librarian when I asked
about or inquired about 1898 you wanted
to know why I was told that yes they had
something but they kept it under lock
and key the story of Wilmington in 1898
still isn't widely known what happened
here and what's now just this empty
patch of grass would radically change
racial politics in North Carolina this
is the story of an American election but
also of something we don't usually find
in American history the violent
overthrow of a democratically elected
government
in the late 1800s Wilmington North
Carolina was the state's largest city it
had a majority black population and
historians today describe it as a rarity
in the post-civil war american south
wilmington prior to November 1898 was
what the new south could be at the cusp
of the 20th century there was an unusual
degree of black prosperity in Wilmington
there were successful black
entrepreneurs doctors teachers but also
black elected officials and for a time
that was true throughout the state take
a look at the politicians on this poster
of the 1889 North Carolina House of
Representatives here at the bottom are
black Republican representatives some
from Wilmington North Carolina also sent
four black Republicans to the US
Congress between 1875 and 1899 the
Democratic and Republican parties of
1898 in many ways occupied opposite
parts of the political spectrum than
they do today most African Americans
were voting for the Republican Party and
the Democratic Party was white voters
almost exclusively white supremacy was
the central focus of the platform for
the Democratic Party Republicans in
North Carolina were successful in part
because of a third party called the
populist party made up of mostly white
farmers fed up with the tough economic
times North Carolina's populist s'
joined up with Republicans to form what
they called the fusion party and in the
elections of 1894 and 1896 the fusion
party defeated the Democrats in sweeping
victory statewide that meant North
Carolina now had a government that
shared power between black and white
politicians including a newly elected
Republican governor together they moved
towards reforms that would favor black
Americans and working-class whites this
was something that
Democratic Party folks were not simply
not going to accept a multiracial
government wasn't just a disappointment
for Democrats it was more like a
humiliation they needed a plan to take
back control of the state in the next
election
so party leaders like phirni Fuld
Simmons future US Senator Charles a [ __ ]
future North Carolina governor and this
man Alfred Moore Waddell came up with
one to beat the fusion Party by luring
white populist voters away from their
alliance with black voters Wilmington
with a large black population and a
local fusion government in power would
be a focus of their campaign the state
Democratic Party handbook for 1898 laid
out their goal consolidate the white
vote by stoking white anger and
resentment it said this is a white man's
country and white men must control and
govern it their most effective tool was
the media one of North Carolina's
biggest newspapers was a Democratic
Party mouthpiece
it ran racist political cartoons
throughout 1898
not everybody was literate in 1898 but
to see a political cartoon of the type
that ran you may not be able to read it
but you know exactly what it means
many of the cartoons were centered on
the threat of Negro rule even though the
fusion government was mostly white they
also played up another fear black men
threatening white women became a theme
white men need to do all that they can
to protect white womanhood this was all
part of North Carolina Democratic
strategy but it echoed the National
racist rhetoric of the time in one
speech that Democrats printed in
Wilmington paper a prominent Georgia
writer named Rebecca Felton said if it
takes lynching a black man a day to
protect white womanhood I say Lynch her
speech prompted a wilmington black man
named Alex Manley
owner of the black run Daily Record
newspaper to respond with a column he
made a simple observation that at the
time was shocking that white women who
had liaisons with black men did so
voluntarily and enthusiastically manly
wrote every Negro lynched is called a
big burly black brute when in fact many
were sufficiently attractive for white
girls to fall in love with them manly
pretty much said in a nutshell sometimes
white women choose to be with black men
Manley's editorial became another tool
for Democrats newspapers reprinted it
called it a horrid slander and ran
comments about it on a daily basis it
was just a few months before the
election and white voters were angry by
the time the election rolls around on
November 8 black voters Republican
voters had been thoroughly intimidated
here by all accounts the elections of
1898 were a sham the Democratic Party
had a paramilitary group called the red
shirts they attacked and blocked black
residents from voting at a rally just
before the election Alfred Moore Waddell
provoked the crowds he said Negro office
holding on at once and forever be
brought to an end even if we have to
choke the current of the Cape Fear River
with carcasses the votes were counted
and the Democrats won Democratic
candidates won every seat they had a
candidate up for election and but some
local fusionist politicians remained in
power because their seats hadn't been up
for reelection like the white Republican
mayor and the Board of Aldermen and of
course the election did nothing to undo
the economic power black folks held in
the city the Democrats had won the
election but their goal of total white
supremacist control remained out of
reach and so they engineered what was
essentially a coup d'etat
the day after the election at a
gathering for white men in Wilmington
the Democrats unveiled a document called
the white declaration of independence
it contained an ultimatum Cynthia Brown
whose descendants were in Wilmington
back in 1898 is a historian at her
church where there's a preserved copy of
the Declaration from the next day's
newspaper we will no longer be ruled
they would strip black men of voting
rights they would give white men a large
part of the employment heretofore given
to black men and as for Alex Manley
we demand that he leave this city
forever within 24 hours the next morning
hundreds of white men marched to the
offices of the Daily Record Manley was
gone he had fled to save his own life
they set the daily record building on
fire this is where it once stood once
the white leadership destroyed
Alex man Lee's printing press they
destroyed one way in which the
african-american community in Wilmington
could organize itself and keep itself
informed
at City Hall the mayor and Board of
Aldermen were forced out there's 200
armed men in City Hall at the time they
didn't do it of their own free will and
as they resigned a new member selected
by the Democratic Party was voted into
office
Waddell who once threatened to fill the
Cape Fear River with black bodies was
the new mayor of Wilmington meanwhile
the mob had grown to about 2,000 men and
the violence spilled into the streets in
these photos X's mark where the first
black residents were killed the stories
are that they were dumped into the river
and they are varying stories about how
many people were killed I see 40 to 60
clearly as fatalities as a result of the
violence but I think it was higher many
black residents hid for days in the
swamps and the wooded cemeteries in the
city including Cynthia's
great-grandmother and thousands of other
residents fled Wilmington never to
return shortly afterward Democrats
printed booklets celebrating a glorious
victory and in the newspapers depicted
black residents as the instigators this
image is a gross misrepresentation of
what actually happened during 1898
you know what you see is
african-american men with guns not white
men with machine guns the city never
regained its black majority population
Jim Crow laws like literacy tests and
poll taxes that prevented black people
from voting were immediately enacted and
Wilmington spirit of black opportunity
was crushed black political
representation in the state was over it
would be 90 years until North Carolina
elected its next black Congress member
Wilmington did a really great job of
covering up a very dark pass for a very
long time over the years the textbooks
on North Carolina's history have
struggled to accurately describe what
happened in 1898 this one from 1933 says
the situation was unfortunate for both
races and this one from 1978 doesn't
have that much more detail but they both
praised Charles a hawk a politician who
helped perpetrate the riot they say he
had a keen mind and a kind heart and
that in fact he was one of the best
friends that the colored people had in
the state it's a legacy that North
Carolina has yet to fully undo the names
of the perpetrators are on Wilmington
school buildings and city parks but the
legacy is also bigger than those names
turn on the news and the state's long
history of political suppression echoes
to a strict new voter ID law in North
Carolina racial gerrymandering and a
push for new voting maps the court says
the republican-led legislature redrew
congressional districts along racial
lines violating the Constitution there's
a tremendous amount of intimidation that
is still felt by the black community it
doesn't have to be masked ma'am and
violence in the streets the strategy
shifts towards designing state laws in
such a way that you could exclude blacks
from voter participation the subliminal
pursuit of continuing the white
declaration of independence and if you
don't see it for what it really is
it can happen all over again
[Music]